quien con 100 años logra no sólo
convertirse en un veterano de guerra
sino recaudar más de 40 millones de
dólares para el servicio público de
salud que guarden un minuto de silencio
en el parlamento en honor a su memoria y
que miles lo recuerden como un héroe
eso fue lo que consiguió tomar en un
siglo de vida dedicado al servicio
militar británico al apoyo a la
comunidad y a una muestra de solidaridad
que en sus últimos meses dejó una huella
imborrable en reino unido pues ya fue
simplemente extraordinario la gente
decía que necesitaban algo en lo que
apoyarse que sus rodillas se estaban
moviendo y decían o hiciste mi año con
solo ver a la familia
y es que con su figura encorvada su
caminador y sus chaquetas llenas de
medallas el capitán marc como era
conocido se transformó en todo un
símbolo en medio de la pandemia este
valiente ex militar que sobrevivió a la
segunda guerra mundial y superó un
cáncer de piel hizo de sus habituales
caminatas para recuperarse de una
fractura de cadera el motor de una obra
social recaudar fondos para el sistema
de salud
se propuso esta meta el 6 de abril de
luego de escuchar en la radio que
cientos de médicos y enfermeras no
contaban con los elementos de protección
para atender a los pacientes con
coronavirus en reinounido
su objetivo fue caminar si entramos del
patio de su casa que tenía 25 metros de
largo antes de cumplir los 100 años el
pasado 30 de abril lo logro recaudó la
astronómica cifra de más de 40 millones
de dólares y además entrar en el listado
del libro mundial de récords guinness
moore fue nombrado caballero por la
reina isabel tras su hazaña económica en
favor de la red sanitaria británica que
fue alcanzada justo cuando un reino
unido-- permanecía bajo un estricto
confinamiento a causa de la propagación
del cob y 19 virus que finalmente
terminó por acabar con su vida el 3 de
febrero pero que no consiguió borrar su
legado
[Música]